Namo Tassa Bhagavato Arahato Sambha Sambhudassa Namo Tassa Bhagavato Arahato Sambha Sambhudassa Namo Tassa Bhagavato Arahato Sambha Sambhudassa
Hommage to the Buddha, the blessed, noble and fully self-enlightened one.
So, this evening, I'm going to try and tackle the problem of happiness.
Just out of interest, to look at the three different...
modèles.
Ça pourrait être intéressant.
Désolé.
Cette soirée, juste pour regarder trois modèles différents.
Ces modèles différents.
Dans, devons-nous dire, l'idée simple chrétienne, c'est que
Dieu vous appelle d'une façon, et le diable vous appelle de l'autre.
Et l'être humain a la liberté d'arbitre.
La liberté d'arbitre, malheureusement, n'est pas un concept que vous trouverez, je crois, soit en Grèce ancienne, soit en Ouest.
C'est intéressant de constater que le libre arbitre n'est pas un concept qu'on trouve dans la Grèce ancienne et dans l'Europe.
Et peut-être que c'est là qu'il faut chercher le fondement de l'individualisme occidental.
Donc il nous faut remercier Saint Augustin.
Dans le modèle freudien, nous avons simplement une répétition de cette idée, mais placée dans une langue psychologique.
Nous avons donc le superego, et le id, et l'ego est supposé négocier un chemin à travers ces idées.
ces deux roches.
Et nous pouvons aussi le voir dans le modèle bouddhiste.
C'est-à-dire, ces profondeurs, ces profondeurs
dans le modèle bouddhiste il y a les attitudes qui sont bienfaisantes et habiles et celles qui ne sont pas habiles et pas bienfaisantes.
Les chrétiens, selon saint Augustin, le verraient comme un problème de libre arbitre.
Et je pense que
Freud n'espérait pas plus qu'une accommodation à la vie, un arrangement avec la vie.
Il ne voyait pas de fin possible à la souffrance.
Le royaume des cieux est toujours face aux chrétiens.
Et rappelez-vous que Jésus a dit que le royaume des cieux était en nous.
Pour le Bouddha, ce qui nous a aidés, c'était la discrimination.
Ce qui nous a aidés à décider de quelle façon aller, c'était la discrimination, la possibilité de nous distinguer.
Donc,
Le chemin du Bouddha est plus en rapport avec la compréhension.
Parce que quand nous comprenons comment nous créons ces problèmes, évidemment, nous allons essayer d'éviter de le faire.
Donc maintenant, prendre la parole « bonheur » pour signifier
tout ce que vous voulez, ce qui vous rend heureux.
Le Bouddha a parlé du fait que les gens pensent que le Nibbana, c'est un paradis des sens.
Et puis il y avait ces magnifiques états mentaux que vous pouviez développer grâce aux pratiques de concentration.
Il semble dire que oui, ils sont tous nirvana mais ils ne sont pas le vrai nirvana.
Donc le vrai nirvana était quelque chose de plus que le monde sensuel.
C'était quelque chose de transcendant.
Il y a eu une très bonne compilation de textes.
C'était rassemblé par Ajan, Amaro et Passano.
Certains d'entre vous le connaissent.
Amaro.
Oui.
And it's called The Island.
Il s'appelle Lille, The Island.
You can download it as a text onto your e-reader.
Vous pouvez le télécharger au format PDF pour votre lecteur e-reader.
And with Google Translate, no problem.
Encore une fois, avec Google Traduction, pas de problème.
And...
Je pense que c'est un bon livre à lire, surtout avec beaucoup de désespoir que les gens qui entrent dans le Buddhisme ont.
C'est un bon livre, particulièrement en s'agissant du thème des croyances ?
Yeah, of the disbelief in something transcendental.
D'accord, le scepticisme par rapport à quelque chose de transcendant.
Yeah.
Que les gens ont en abordant le bouddhisme.
Materialistic scientists.
Materialist scientists.
C'est scientifique, matériel, c'est ça ?
Comment le Bouddha veut-il que nous soyons heureux ?
Il parle de personnes qui vont de l'obscurité vers la lumière.
Et une grande partie de ses enseignements concernent comment devenir heureux, comment se rendre heureux.
et le premier est le vipassana que nous avons fait c'est la purification qui se passe qui est une partie du processus de nous rendre heureux c'est ce processus de purification qui a lieu, qui fait partie de ce qui peut nous rendre heureux donc quand nous ressentons de l'angoisse ou de la solitude ou de la tristesse en les observant
Quand on ressent de la tristesse, de la colère ou d'autres états négatifs et qu'on les observe, il ne s'agit pas seulement de les faire s'épuiser.
C'est un processus de transformation.
C'est ce qui m'est venu à la maison dans une expérience particulière que j'ai eue.
J'étais très en colère contre mon maître.
En fait, j'aurais pu avoir étranglé son nez.
Et je suis allé pour un rétreat personnel de deux semaines.
Et donc je suis parti pour une retraite solitaire de deux semaines.
Et j'avais un camarade avec moi qui très gentiment cuisinait et s'occupait de la propriété.
Et pendant que je souffrais sur le coussin, il lisait « Lord of the Rings ».
Il est maintenant lecteur en philosophie.
Et maintenant, il est lecteur à l'université en philosophie.
Je méditais avec toute cette colère, cette déception, etc. Et j'essayais de...
J'ai proposé de l'amener à ma tête.
volontairement je l'ai amené à mon maître et à chaque fois qu'il y avait son visage en face de moi je sentais ses ressentis donc j'allais au devant, j'observais ses ressentis et je restais avec eux et à mon amagement
sous mes yeux à mon grand étonnement ils ont commencé à se transformer en un ressenti chaleureux de compassion ça n'est arrivé qu'une fois mais c'était suffisant pour prouver qu'il y avait plus à faire
cela suffit pour moi à prouver qu'il ne s'agit pas seulement de laisser ces émotions se dissiper il y a aussi une transformation naturelle qui a lieu à l'intérieur du coeur quand vous laissez le coeur agir c'est une chose incroyable le coeur sait comment se réhabiliter
C'est une chose étonnante, le cœur sait comment se guérir lui-même.
Comme le corps.
Si vous vous coupez, vous n'allez pas vous-même vous arranger pour que les cellules cicatrisent.
Ce que vous faites, c'est que vous vous arrangez pour que la plaie soit désinfectée.
C'est le corps qui se guérit lui-même.
Alors, quand nous ne nous interprétons pas avec le cœur, mais nous le permettons d'exprimer à nous-mêmes, c'est en nous guérissant.
Si vous prenez par exemple la solitude,
tout le monde ressent la solitude à un moment et ce que nous tendons à faire, bien sûr, c'est de s'en sortir, de trouver une distraction mais si on se situe tranquillement avec ça
Mais si nous méditons tranquillement avec la solitude, en présence de la solitude, parfois vous pouvez écouter le langage de la solitude.
Tu ne sers à rien, tu ne vaux rien, personne ne t'aime.
Et ça se transforme ensuite en une forme de haine de soi.
Comment quiconque pourrait-il t'aimer ?
Mais si vous restez avec ce ressenti et que vous le laissez arriver à son terme,
à la toute fin de quoi pensez-vous que vous feriez l'expérience à la fin de ce ressenti le versant positif le fait d'être avec soi-même
C'est donc l'approche difficile de la joie.
Mais malheureusement, elle est nécessaire.
Vous pourrez lire dans les livres sur la psychologie positive qu'il existe trois types de bonheurs.
Le premier, c'est le bonheur des sens.
C'est le bonheur des sens.
Dans la compréhension bouddhiste, ça inclurait tous les types de plaisirs qui sont transitoires, qui sont temporaires.
Et évidemment, ce qu'il y a de décevant, c'est qu'ils sont temporaires.
Et donc,
quand nous appréhendons quelque chose juste pour ces choses elles tendent à avoir une certaine épaisseur dans elles j'aime toujours citer Woody Allen il a dit que c'est vrai
le sexe juste pour lui-même est une expérience vide mais comme les expériences vides vont mais s'il s'agit des expériences vides notre effort est de trouver une façon d'être avec celles-ci
la très forte consiste à essayer d'être avec ces expériences là sans pour autant leur demander de nous rendre heureux si nous entendons le mot heureux comme signifiant un état constant, éternel, permanent
Si nous les acceptons tels qu'ils sont, alors pas de problème.
J'y reviendrai à la fin de mon discours de ce soir, mais de repenser, ramener ces expériences à l'esprit à la fin de la journée.
Oui.
Parce que souvent, notre mémoire ne va retenir que les choses abominables qui nous sont arrivées pendant la journée.
Si nous ne contemplons que ce qui nous a fait nous sentir mal, qu'est-ce qui peut nous arriver d'autre que des états désagréables ?
Le deuxième, vous verrez, est pris d'Aristote.
Son terme était, je pense, eudaimonia.
Ça signifie être complètement absorbé dans ce que vous faites.
Ça signifie être complètement absorbé par ce que vous êtes en train de faire.
Les athlètes parlent d'être dans la zone.
C'est un peu comme...
un film où vous vous absorbez complètement.
Et le paradoxe, c'est que quand vous êtes totalement heureux, vous ne vous en rendez pas compte.
Dès que vous vous en rendez compte, vous le perdez.
Si
Si ça vous arrive pendant la méditation, tout à coup il y a ces moments d'extase.
Et on se retrouve absorbé dans ces états.
Évidemment, l'erreur que nous faisons, c'est « Ah, génial, la prochaine fois que je méditerai, je vais de nouveau rechercher ces états-là.
» Évidemment, il n'y a que le malheur qui nous attend, la déception.
Ils restent dans notre mémoire comme
Évidemment, si nous pouvons accepter ces états simplement tels qu'ils viennent, ils restent dans notre mémoire comme des possibilités de ressentir de la joie.
Ce qu'ils ont observé, c'est que ce qui nous rend vraiment heureux, c'est que nos vies aient du sens.
Dans un passage que je lisais, on disait que les soldats qui se suicident avaient perdu le sens de leur vie, ils ne voyaient plus le sens de leur vie.
Ils ne voyaient plus de raison de vivre.
Ah !
C'est la raison pour laquelle la plupart des gens se suicident.
Paradoxalement, nous trouvons notre plus grand sens lorsque nous faisons quelque chose qui est plus grand que nous-mêmes.
Paradoxalement, on trouve... Notre vie prend le plus de sens quand nous faisons quelque chose qui est plus grand que simplement nous-mêmes.
Quand vous travaillez pour une charité, pour un idéal, pour un business.
Pour un idéal.
C'est pourquoi
c'est la raison pour laquelle les djihadistes sont tellement heureux maintenant leur vie a tellement de sens et c'est une immense joie de se faire exploser et quand ils meurent il y a toutes ces vierges qui les attendent
Donc, nous pouvons voir ici que peut-être le sens n'est pas assez suffisant.
Et cela nous ramène vraiment à la position du Bouddha sur l'éthique.
Je veux dire, c'était son insight sur son réveil.
c'était sa réalisation au moment de son éveil c'était la découverte que c'était ses décisions éthiques qui l'avaient conduit au bout du compte à trouver la fin à découvrir la fin de la souffrance l'éthique dans son plus grand sens signifie simplement les relations
L'éthique au sens le plus large signifie simplement les relations.
Nos relations avec les êtres humains, avec les animaux, avec la nature.
Il y a évidemment une manière d'agir qui est à la fois asoélante
Ce n'est pas toujours le cas.
Si votre maison est infectée par les rats, vous avez un problème éthique.
Oui.
Alors, comment le Bouddha
nous apprend à utiliser nos décisions éthiques pour développer le cœur magnifique.
Oui, magnifique, beau, magnifique, magnifique.
Quand il donne la parole aux gens de l'âge,
quand il parle à des laïcs il suit toujours ce même processus il commence par la générosité ensuite il parle de la moralité ensuite il parle des états et quand il sent que les gens sont prêts
Et quand il sent que l'assistance est prête, il parle des quatre nobles vérités.
Il y a la souffrance.
La générosité est une clé de l'enseignement.
Même un voleur peut être généreux, selon lui.
Il peut être généreux en utilisant les choses qu'il vient de vous voler.
À chaque fois que nous sommes généreux, nous laissons filer, nous donnons quelque chose que nous aurions pu utiliser pour nous-mêmes.
à une organisation, ça veut dire que je ne peux pas utiliser cette fortune pour télécharger des nouveaux morceaux sur mon iPad.
Donc dans l'acte de donner, il y a un acte de renonciation.
Dans l'acte du don, il y a un acte de renoncement.
Évidemment, je peux aussi donner de mon temps.
Quand les gens font quelque chose pour une œuvre charitable, comme rendre visite aux malades, par exemple, c'est aussi une renonciation de temps qu'ils pourraient avoir passé.
Just for themselves.
You may have had the experience when a friend has said to you something like I'm going to decorate my house or my flat this weekend and you have jumped in and said oh I'll come and give you a hand.
Ça vous est peut-être arrivé qu'un ami vous dise qu'il allait rénover sa maison, repeindre sa maison pendant le week-end et que vous ayez spontanément proposé, « Je vais te donner un gouvernement.
» Et juste après, « Pourquoi j'ai dit ça ?
» Et après, vous devez trouver une excuse.
« Mon chien est malade, il faut que j'y aille.
»
Sur le moment, il y a cette générosité spontanée.
Et ensuite, il y a ce retour.
Je préférais passer mon samedi à aller voir le football.
il y a une tendance naturelle à la générosité mais quand cette générosité implique un sacrifice c'est là qu'il est important de développer la qualité du renoncement du renoncement
que nous faisons quelque chose pour quelqu'un d'autre et qu'on observe que ça les rend heureux il y a aussi de la joie qui survient en nous à ce moment-là donc le processus de la générosité c'est le processus de la croissance de la mudita, la joie sympathique
Et si nous trouvons que nous avons de la difficulté à être généreux, une façon d'être généreux, c'est par la gratitude.
Quand nous nous sentons gréfeux envers quelqu'un, nous voulons naturellement remettre le cadeau.
Quand on ressent de la gratitude envers quelqu'un, on a naturellement envie de lui rendre ce qu'il nous a donné.
On a envie de lui donner un cadeau.
Dans notre société, où tant de choses sont prises en compte, on a perdu ce magnifique
la capacité de vraiment ressentir une grande gratitude.
Ou je devrais dire que j'ai perdu la capacité.
Les gens se moquent de l'éducation.
Ils ont eu le service de santé.
Les gens se plaignent de l'éducation qu'ils reçoivent, des services médicaux, etc.
En oubliant complètement que l'éducation était gratuite.
Et que pour la plupart des services médicaux, si vous avez une maladie grave, vous ne pourriez pas payer.
Et pourtant, ces services sont souvent donnés par la société aux individus.
Et quand vous considérez le problème que le président Obama a eu en passant par une loi de bien-être juste pour aider les gens à avoir des soins médicaux basiques,
Si vous prenez en considération les difficultés qu'a rencontré le président Obama pour faire passer une loi qui visait simplement à donner à chacun une assurance médicale de base, vous vous rendez compte à quel point on peut devenir égoïste.
Souvent formulé dans un langage qui dit vous devriez pouvoir vous occuper de vous-même.
Mais cela...
On néglige de prendre en considération que nous ne sommes pas ces individus seuls qui pourront gouverner notre propre vie.
Mais nous sommes tous liés les uns aux autres.
Et cette capacité de voir cette interconnection permet à la compassion d'arriver naturellement.
Donc déjà, dans ce processus de générosité, de renonciation et de gratitude, les cœurs grandissent tout le temps.
Par la générosité, le renoncement et la gratitude, par ce processus, le cœur croît, grandit tout le temps.
Vous devez vous engager dans certains exercices si vous voulez développer ces qualités.
Par exemple, nous parlions de ne pas partir de l'ordinateur
Nous parlions hier de ne pas quitter l'ordinateur pour vous jeter sur le lit pour dormir.
Après avoir joué à ces jeux.
Ou après avoir regardé la télévision.
Simplement de vous asseoir tranquillement et de réfléchir à votre journée.
Et juste considérer
Prendre conscience des petites gentillesses que vous avez données et que vous avez reçues.
Quelqu'un vous a peut-être fait une tasse de thé au travail.
Vous avez peut-être cédé la place à quelqu'un d'autre dans une file d'attente parce que cette personne était pressée.
vous avez peut-être pardonné quelqu'un qui vous avait marché sur le pied dans le tram.
Quand vous suivez le cours de la journée comme ça et que vous attrapez, vous prenez note de ces petits moments, vous prenez conscience que le cœur commence à se...
Chanter.
Et ensuite, réfléchir à l'ensemble de la journée et prendre conscience de toutes ces petites joies.
Pendant la pause de midi, vous avez marché et vous avez été enchanté, charmé par le chant d'un oiseau.
Et toutes ces choses, nous tendons à les empêcher et à nous souvenir de toutes ces choses misérables.
Toutes ces irritations que les gens nous ont causées.
Et ces politiciens.
Et nous permettons à l'esprit de rester sur cela, donc bien sûr, c'est le cœur que nous construisons.
Et nous laissons l'esprit rester là-dedans, et évidemment, c'est ces états-là qui prennent de l'ampleur.
Et bien sûr, il y a aussi la pratique de la Metta.
Vous voyez, juste envoyer des messages de bonheur du cœur.
Simplement envoyer des messages de bienveillance à partir du cœur.
Comme je vous l'ai dit, au début, vous aurez peut-être l'impression que le cœur ne réagit pas, qu'il est indifférent et anesthésié.
Par exemple, quand vous rentrez dans une chambre avec des gens, normalement, nous venons avec une vue fixée.
habituellement, nous venons avec une vue fixe, une vue prédéterminée.
Nous entrons en cherchant quelqu'un ou en nous attendant à quelque chose.
Mais si vous venez entrer dans une chambre et que la chambre vous vienne,
Mais si vous entrez dans une pièce et que vous donnez la permission à ce que la pièce vienne vers vous, vienne devant de vous, c'est cette histoire de conscience, de conscience ouverte.
Et avant d'entrer dans la pièce, vous mettez votre cœur dans une position de bienveillance.
Et en entrant dans la pièce, c'est la pièce qui vient au devant de vous, au lieu qu'il y ait une réaction, il y a une réponse du cœur basée sur ce cœur de bienveillance, à ce que la pièce amène.
Il y a beaucoup de choses que nous pouvons faire pour générer ce bonheur dans notre propre cœur.
si nous mettons ceci dans un conteneur éthique et le Bouddha a dit nous faisons ce qui est bon pour nous ce qui est bon pour les autres ce qui est bon pour nous et pour les autres donc parfois c'est très spécifique vous parlez simplement d'un autre quelqu'un
Parfois c'est très spécifique, vous parlez simplement de quelqu'un d'autre.
Parfois c'est un large groupe de personnes.
Et parfois vous allez inclure tous les êtres.
Si nous passons de cette base, c'est très difficile de voir nous-mêmes soutenir le tueur d'une autre personne.
nous partons de cette base-là, ça devient très difficile de soutenir, que nous soutenions l'assassinat de quelqu'un d'autre.
Peut-être uniquement dans les cas d'auto-défense.
Donc, pour récapituler,
le but de l'ipassana sur le plan psychologique c'est la purification du cœur mais il faut nous rappeler qu'en même temps que la purification il y a un processus de transformation et puis il y a aussi
Et il y a ces exercices positifs dans lesquels nous pouvons nous engager.
l'humanité, avec le monde.
Et le discours sur comment établir l'amitié amoureuse dit que nous devons donner ce bonheur à tous les êtres dans toutes les directions.
le discours sur l'établissement de la bienveillance dit qu'il nous faut donner cette bienveillance à tous les êtres dans toutes les directions le chant que nous faisons le chant que nous faisons vient de ce soupe et cette qualité de générosité
C'est quelque chose que vous pouvez vraiment regarder et voir.
Si vous n'avez pas vu ce processus de gratitude, renonciation, générosité, joie.
Si vous n'avez pas vu ce processus, alors donnez-vous un exercice.
Je pense.
Give yourself an exercise.
Sorry, I'll start again.
If you haven't seen that process of renunciation, gratitude, renunciation,
Si vous n'avez pas observé ce processus de gratitude, de renoncement, de générosité et de joie, faites un exercice.
Tout ce qu'il vous faut faire, c'est prendre en considération quelque chose pour quoi vous vous sentez reconnaissant.
et ensuite vous dire à vous même je vais donner un peu de ma fortune ou un peu de mon temps pour que d'autres puissent ressentir ce même bénéfice et si vous le faites personnellement à quelqu'un
Et si vous le faites personnellement, envers quelqu'un d'autre, vous voyez qu'il y a de la joie qui émerge, qui apparaît.
Je ne crois pas qu'il vous sera possible d'empêcher la résonance de cette joie dans votre propre cœur.
Mais il y a un avertissement.
Et c'est le problème du « do go down ».
C'est le problème des do-gooders, des gens qui veulent absolument faire du bien.
Les do-gooders, quand ils vous font du bien, ils veulent que vous leur fassiez se sentir bien, eux.
le do-gooder wants to do you the good they want to do you whether you want it or not to make them happy and that's where you find people saying things like
Et là que les gens disent, mais je ne comprends pas, je les ai tellement aidés, pourtant ils ne veulent plus me voir.
Faites attention à ça.
La corruption, c'est que nous commençons à faire ces choses dans le but d'être heureux.
Évidemment, dans ce cas, ça devient égoïste.
Je ne peux qu'espérer que mes mots vous aident.
Que dans votre pratique du Dhamma, vous puissiez faire croître un bonheur infini.
Et éventuellement atteindre l'infinite bonheur lui-même de Nirvana.
et finalement atteindre ce bonheur infini lui-même qu'est le nirvana.
Sula, rather than later.
Au plus tôt.
Sadhu, sadhu, sadhu.